yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
if you enjoy a good Easter egg hunt than
x-men apocalypse has plenty to keep you
busy and in this video I'm gonna run
through all the Easter eggs and
references I spotted it in the film of
course there will be spoilers ahead so
if you want to avoid any spoilers click
here for my spoiler free review or
comeback after you've seen the movie and
as promised I'm giving away the first of
two packs of x-men apocalypse merch on
this video to enter the giveaway you
just need to subscribe and leave a
comment or reply to a comment about your
favorite Easter Egg in the movie one of
the movies best moments is when Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine emerges from his
weapon XL in full-on Berserker mode the
headgear and cables belts and gadgets
around his waist and the spikes in his
torso for a reference to his original
training gear from the Weapon X comics
written and illustrated by Barry
windsor-smith and the red light we see
on his helmet is a nod to the red visor
on his virtual reality helmet in the
comics the location where all this scene
takes place is alkali Lake which we saw
in the first x-men trilogy and in x-men
origins Wolverine although with a change
timeline since Days of Future past the
Wolverine Weapon X we see here is a new
version the moment where Jean Grey
touches Wolverines head soothed him and
restores a part of his memory is a nod
to the relationship between Wolverine
and fomka Johnson's Jean Grey in the
original x-men trilogy even if here it
feels rather age-inappropriate it's also
an interesting twist on the last stand
where it was Logan who tried to soothe
Jean Grey from her Dark Phoenix elf and
there are lots of hints that the Dark
Phoenix saga will be revisited in the
x-men movie universe hopefully in a more
satisfying way than it was previously
when gene wakes up from her nightmare
the talk between her and Charles about a
dark power inside her and visions of
flames is an indication of what's to
come and her words that I'm afraid
someday I'm going to hurt someone are
also a nod to how she killed Scott
Summers in the last stand in the final
showdown Jean learns to harness the
powerful Phoenix energy when Charles
pleads with her to unleash it so they
can defeat apocalypse and the moment is
completed with the image of a burning
bird around Jean and apocalypse
proclaiming ball is revealed
thanks to the popularity of
quicksilver's amazing frozen time
sequence and Days of Future past Evan
Peters gets not just one but two slow-mo
scenes and x-men apocalypse and the
pizza dogs at Quicksilver rescues is an
easter egg from the comics where Hawkeye
rescues a dog called lucky
aka pizza dog and when Quicksilver
surfed out of the exploding X mansion on
a table it's a cool visual nod to the
Silver Surfer from the comics and of
course the Fantastic Four 2007 sequel
rise of the Silver Surfer there's also a
wink to the x-men themed V energy drink
ad starring Evan Peters when Quicksilver
stops to take a sip of the tab soda can
from a girl holding a drink during the
x-mansion explosion by the way after the
hints from Days of Future past we also
get an amusing confirmation that magneto
is indeed quicksilver's father as per
the comics the Six Million Dollar Man
t-shirt worn by Quicksilver is a nod to
apocalypse director Bryan Singer's
rumored plans to make a big-screen
version of the seventies TV show the Six
Million Dollar Man and quicksilver's
room has some cool pop-culture
references from the 1980s including a
Miss pac-man arcade game and the Knight
Rider theme playing on his TV blob from
x-men origins Wolverine makes a brief
appearance as the opponent angel knocks
out before Nightcrawler is brought in to
the mutant cage fight this scenes also
call back to our first introduction to
Wolverine in the very first x-men movie
when he's cage fighting in a bar by the
way in a deleted scene from x-men
origins Wolverine he was heavily implied
that blob was killed but in the movie's
new timeline blob or their unconscious
seems to be alive there's a reference to
night crawlers comic book and x-men 2
origins in the circus when he's
introduced to the cage fight the fact
that it's Raven aka mystique who rescues
Nightcrawler in East Berlin is also a
shout out to their history in the comic
books where mystique is actually
nightcrawlers mother and his father is
Azazel when the cage fight announcer
introduces angel as the angel of death
it not only foreshadows his becoming
apocalypse his horsemen death in this
film but it's also a reference to the
same thing happening in the comics in
the movie like in the comics apocalypse
also transforms angel into archangel
pushing him through a painful process of
shedding his old feather wings and
growing new metal wands that
shoot metal feathers like knives by the
way the track that plays during this
scene is appropriately enough heavy
metal band Metallica as the four
horsemen the underground business at the
mutant Caliban runs in the movie is a
nod to the time he spent in the comics
with the underground mutant community
the Morlocks in the comics Caliban has
the power to sense and track where the
mutants are within a certain distance
and in this film his job is to track
down mutants for the right price the
comic book Caliban becomes apocalypse is
horsemen pestilence but in the movie
it's his henchwoman psylocke who takes
on this role psylocke has a rather
limited role in x-men apocalypse but she
still gets a number of nods to her comic
book characteristics she gets a comic
book faithful albeit in practical
costume and a pair of pink telekinetic
katanas which she can slice through just
about anything with including as we see
in this movie a car Magneto story of
trying to live with his family among
ordinary people in Eastern Europe is
based on a similar storyline from the
x-men comics where he lives with the
Romani woman called Magda in the comics
they have a daughter called Aniyah
rather than Nina and she's called in the
movie similar to the film tragedy before
magneto when his daughter dies in a fire
when police prevent magneto from going
in to save Vania he lashes out and kills
them all as he does in the movie comic
book magneto also loses his wife Magda
when she flees afraid of what he's
become by the way in the comics Magda
later gives birth to Magneto's children
Wanda and Pietro aka Scott Witch and
Quicksilver in the movie during his time
in Poland magneto takes on the alias
Henrik which is a nod to when he changed
his name in the comics to Erik Lehnsherr
which is of course the name he goes by
in the x-men movie universe Magneto's
daughter Nina's ability to communicate
telepathically with animals such as the
deer we see by the house or the bird she
uses to attack the police is a reference
to the comic book mutant men Lee aka
nature girl who has antlers on her head
and who can bond with and control
animals at the end of the movie Cyclops
gets a new visor and an iconic costume
complete with shoulder straps similar to
the Gimli design in the 1990s comics the
argument the school jock has with Scott
about having his eyes on his girl
there's a little inside joke to the
rivalry between james marsden psyche
some Wolverine over Scott's girlfriend
Jean Grae in the original x-men movie
trilogy the jacket Scott Summers bully
at school words has the words Wedgewood
pirate on the back possibly a wink to
the space pirate course sir who's
Scott's father in the comics especially
as Scott says that his bully looks old
enough to be the father of their female
classmate storms Mohawk matches the
Hearst our makeover she got in the 1983
comic uncanny x-men number 173 and her
pickpocketing skills also have their
origins in the comics where an orphan
storm learned the art of stealing on the
streets of Cairo and even tried to pick
professor X's pocket mystique gets the
new sleeveless white costume by the end
of the movie in reference to her classic
white outfits from the comics also at
the end of the movie with steek is
clearly training the new team and
Professor X's danger room there's a
tease of the classic x-men robot foes
the Sentinels as they march into the
danger room for training we last saw the
Sentinels in Days of Future past but the
x-men also previously trained against
the simulated Sentinel at the beginning
of x-men last stand although it feels
like Jubilees role was cut down in the
final edit her character discuss a nice
little Easter Egg to a comic book
origins when she visits the shopping
mall with Scott Jean and Nightcrawler in
the comics Jubilee runs away from an
orphanage and hides out in a shopping
mall discovering her mutant powers while
trying to get away from a security guard
when everyone wakes up at the x-mansion
during jeans nightmare Professor X tells
several young mutants to return to their
rooms referencing Mary Poppins when he
says spit-spot back to bed when Charles
goes to Moyers office and learns she has
a son his reaction not only reflects a
shock and disappointment he feels that
he fancies Moira but it's also a nod to
her son in the comics in the comics
Moira son Kevin becomes a deadly villain
Proteus and Brian singer has mentioned
that he'd like Proteus to appear in a
future x-men movie the scene also
alludes to Charles and Moyers romantic
relationship in the comics and their
kiss at the end of first class when
Charles battles apocalypse the stress of
using his powers causes him to lose his
hair which in the comics happens in his
teens again as a result of his mutant
powers and the way apocalypse grows in
size as he and Charles fight each other
is a nod to his giant-sized in the
comics and how he's able to change his
cipher the opening scene where
apocalypse is trapped in a collapsing
pyramid is an homage to the 1955 movie
land of the Pharaohs in which the
villainous princess played by Joan
Collins is deliberately trapped inside
the Pharaoh's tomb by a huge stone
Magneto's words to Charles that doesn't
it ever wake you up in the middle of the
night the feeling that someday they'll
come for you and your children and
Charles's reply that I feel a great
swirl of pity for the poor soul that
comes to my school looking for trouble
but almost a direct echo of what magneto
and Charles said to each other at the
very end of the first x-men movie and
there's a callback to x-men 2 and
Professor X reads from th White's novel
the once and future king at the
x-mansion at the end of the second x-men
film Charles asked his students if
they'd ever read the book and earlier in
the film magneto is reading it while he
was imprisoned in his plastic cell the
book also makes a number of appearances
in the x-men comics for example in
extinction agender it's said to be
Professor X's favorite book in x-men
apocalypse Charles actually quotes in
the once and future king that the past
must be obliterated and a new start made
let us now start fresh without
remembrance rather than live forward and
backward at the same time which is an
inside joke that pokes fun at the
confusing and oftentimes inconsistent
timeline of the x-men movie franchise as
well as being a clear reference to Days
of Future past in particular there's
also a funny moment when Charles says
about Moira that she looks like she's
burly aged today which again is the
filmmakers poking fun at the franchise's
inconsistencies as actress Rose Byrne
who plays Moira certainly doesn't look
twenty years older than she did in first
class the events of which took place two
decades before this movie and there's
another joke about the x-men franchise
when Jubilee Jean Grey Cyclops and
Nightcrawler exit the movie theatre
having just seen Return of the Jedi when
Jean says we can all agree that the
third one as the worst it's a joke by
writer Simon Kinberg the last stand
which he also Rose is generally
considered to be the worst movie in the
first x-men trilogy
Bryan Singh is a huge Star Trek fan and
building on the Star Trek reference in
Days of Future past the 1967 Star Trek
episode knew mourns for Adonai Asst
plays in the background on the TV at
storms house in Cairo after she brings
apocalypse back to her home the god
Apollo who appears in the episode shares
a similarity with apocalypse calling the
members of the enterprise his children
and later also grown to gigantic size
just like apocalypse does actress Ally
Sheedy plays Scott Summers teacher who
we see educating her students about the
history of the 1973 Paris Peace Accords
in other words the events of Days of
Future past it's fun to see she D
playing a teacher especially as she
orders Scott to see the school principal
for disrupting the class as one of she
DS most famous roles was in director
John Hughes coming-of-age movie The
Breakfast Club where she played
compulsive liar Allison who spends a
whole Saturday in detention with four
other high school students Stanley also
gets a new x-men cameo this time joined
by his wife Joan Lee as they watch the
world's nuclear missiles being fired
into space by apocalypse the
post-credits scene includes a nice tease
for the supervillain mr. sinister in the
scene we see a trio of suited men
walking into the alkali Lake Weapon X
facility with a pic of a vial labeled
Weapon X DNA the vilest son stored in a
briefcase labeled essex court with essex
referring to dr. Nathaniel Essex from
the comics Essex is a Darwinist
geneticists obsessed with developing a
superior species and is transformed into
mr. sinister by non other than
apocalypse and the vial of Weapon X DNA
is a big easter egg to Wolverines female
clone x-23 appearing in either wolverine
3 or future x-men movies and if you'd
like a more detailed breakdown of that
scene and its implications for the x-men
movie universe you can click right here
for my full video on the post credits so
those were all the Easter eggs and
references I supported in x-men
apocalypse but I'm sure you noticed
other ones too and I'd love to hear
about them in the comment section also
make sure you're subscribed for a chance
to win this pack of cool x-men merch and
you can click on the gleam link in the
video description below for bonus ways
to enter the giveaway if you enjoyed
this video check out my full post
credits breakdown of what the mr.
sinister tees means for Wolverine
and other x-men movies and for more
Easter eggs take a look at my video of
all the Easter eggs and references and
Captain America Civil War click any of
the links here to check those out thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers